gehen tier gerade ein video über scannen
anzuklicken übers genen zu reden oder
einfach nur ans gehen zu denken
karlsburg
lernen ist nun anstecken das liegt an
unserer empathie das ist unsere
fähigkeit uns in andere menschen
hineinzuversetzen
so wie wir auch mit anderen menschen
lachen oder weinen
das ist übrigens melanie ich nicht sagen
okay wenn wir sehen wie jemand anderem
etwas passiert dann werden in unserem
gehirn die sogenannten spiegelneuronen
aktiviert und die reagieren dann so als
ob uns das selbst passieren würde so
zucken wir zum beispiel auch zusammen
wenn wir sehen wie sich jemand anderes
mit dem hammer auf den daumen schlägt
aber warum gehen wir überhaupt und wie
kann man es vermeiden lange zeit dachte
man dass man durch gähnen ein sauerstoff
fust bekommt inzwischen hat sich aber
eine andere wissenschaftliche themen
durchgesetzt und zwar soll denen das
gehirn kühlen
zum einen gibt es durch das gähnen eine
ganz einfache luftkühlung zum anderen
werden durch gähnen wie auch durch
strecken puls und durchblutung erhöht
ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen das
gehirn ist an sich schon 0,2 grad wärmer
als das blut durch das s versorgt durch
anstrengung der stress durch müdigkeit
wird es die hier leicht überhitzt die
wärme kann dann durch das
verhältnismäßig kühlen reboot wieder
abgeleitet werden und je mehr blut durch
das gehirn gepumpt wird desto besser wir
diese wärme abgeleitet sagen wir ihr
sitzt in einem meeting und ihr müsst
dringend genen und wollte ich unhöflich
sein
da könnte ja schlechten kühlkette
rausholen expertentipp umgehen besonders
effektiv zu vermeiden konzentriert euch
einfach drauf durch die nase zu atmen
das funktioniert am besten schon schlau
oder ihr werdet erst gar nicht müde weil
ihr einen kleinen powernap einlegt wie
das richtig funktioniert seht ihr hier
drüben ansonsten abonnieren nicht
vergessen dann sehen wir uns nur nicht
nächsten donnerstag wieder